hello I'm the cinema snob and if you're
like me what's the first thing you think
of when you think of Halloween that's
right
leprechauns most of you would connect
this famous icon to Saint Patrick's Day
well that's because most of you are
sheep Halloween is the holiday to be
associated with this mythical creature
don't believe me then just check out
leprechaun finally somebody sees these
creepy bastards for the little demon
fucks that they are this movie realizes
that for footmen and green adds pointy
shoes and high-pitched voices are the
epitome of fear and we're gonna review
this little masterpiece right here -
excuse me
what do you think you're doing I'm the
cinema snob
I'm the cinema snob but it aligned the
cinema snob no I'm the cinema snob
well okay what do you say we review this
anus turkey together I would like that
so it starts out with Warwick Davis as
the Leprechaun looking about as scary as
a midget Lady gaga
hi as they win a choice they fight who
steals be gold I live through the night
seriously this movie is so unbelievably
not scary that just deepens my voice
deeper and deeper deeper and deeper
god damn they got a shit
how the hell you do that voice years of
drinking Crystal Pepsi my friend dick
all right so it's the credits roll we
see a guy named Dan O'Grady comes home
from Ireland to North Dakota must've
been that big Ireland to North Dakota
rush however he manages to bring a bag
of gold with him lot of gold a wee
personal época I got him and made him
show me where as Gorgons you know I'm
surprised they're still showing the
credits after that line I assumed
everybody would just want their name
taken off faster than you can say Bakura
the Leprechaun appears out of the
suitcase in a text the old lady I meet
gold oh come on he didn't kill her she's
just a fucking clod the wife makes a
fine cut of Dean Danny me bowling the
luckily Danny Boy has Irish kryptonite
or in this case a four-leaf clover which
I suppose weakens him we give you more
than gone stuck me forever I'll keep
coming wait a minute what do we miss
bullets can't hurt him but then he
suddenly passed out fuck why was there
even an edit there they just dissolved
to the exact same scene harm drover with
keep you in there forever
so Grady nails the little guy in a box
and trust me that's not as exciting as
it sounds but before he can light the
fucker on fire I guess he has a heart
attack or something
but wait a minute that happened to him
whatever happened to the box no it's
okay he's being looked after by top men
who top men
cut to a mere 10 years later as we see
one of the main characters played by
Jennifer Aniston she's in this movie yep
Jennifer Aniston's old career is pretty
much like David Schwimmer's current
career all right just keep the French
jokes to a minimum can I make no
promises it turns out Aniston and her
father Randy Travis here are staying in
North Dakota for a while and of course
they're staying in the old house where
Darby O'Gill gang banger is how about I
get a hotel somewhere in town and you
can come visit okay I'll pay for it
honey you really think money is all you
need to get behind this line well she is
Jennifer Aniston so she runs into one of
the house painters played by Jim Carrey
bacon here as he's part of a painting
company called three guys that paint
you'll never guess what they do paint no
make them not just comedy relief go for
a beer right now
yeah no drink don't you ever ever drink
that stuff
hey Angie what's this I gotcha oh please
tell me they died I'll pray for us both
so that little twerp where's the
long-haired version of neces named Alex
who you might remember from mr. nanny
and don't tell Mom the babysitter's dead
nevers on good and that big tub of idiot
who's dressed like a racecar bed he's
named Ozzie played by Mark Holton fetch
so we see Jennifer Aniston go downstairs
to give Jim Carey bacon some juice
ah dog what are you doing I just thought
we were shouting animals know only how
they do that
oh okay so after Anacin heads back up
i'll see heads back down swearing he
heard something
he accidentally knocks the four-leaf
clover over which gives the leprechaun
back his powers hey tubby you got a
light for no leprechauns pipe balls
about as good as most Irish cooking I
need me gold so as he tells them all
about the Leprechaun but of course
nobody believes it Hey Hey look up in
the sky so what Ozzy it's just a rainbow
it's a magic rainbow Jack gonna make
this movie good no no they said it's a
magic rainbow not a miracle ring so they
follow the rainbow to where O'Grady hid
the gold when blimp box here actually
swallows one of the coins my guess is he
thought there was chocolate inside
ding offers means we can get your
reparation for what to make you smart
see we can go to the hospital and have
them operate and fix your brain what is
this clovers for Algernon no operation
can make you smart a bit coy the
producers of this movie will have got it
ages ago meanwhile Aniston tries to help
paint the house while the Leprechaun
tries topping over morning Nathan come
on what are you doing
so the leprechaun attacks both Aniston
her father's they tried to get them to
the hospital hey is it me or do you
totally want to see a sitcom called
three guys that paint yeah I can
actually see that happening coming this
fall this CBS once a good-looking
painter once a bumbling doofus and the
other is the boy with the heart of gold
top it all up with a psychotic killing
leprechaun and you have the hit family
sitcom of the year three guys that paint
coming this fall on CBS welcome home so
it's they head to the hospital the
leprechaun finds a mode of
transportation to follow them that's
right folks this is what's gonna try and
scare you throughout the majority of the
film a little guy on a tricycle hey at
least it's more dignified than playing
an Ewok so they take one of the coins to
an expert who tells him that the gold is
real he keeps the coin overnight to
analyze it some more when he senses
something wicked this way comes wicked
or wicked doesn't matter
oh don't act like you can build up
suspense movie you're called leprechaun
and here we finally see what this pot of
shit looks like really that's the scary
makeup he's been given that's not the
least bit frightening I know he was more
intimidating in that kid's film a very
unlucky leprechaun in fact he's actually
scarier looking in that film you're
right he actually looks more scary in
the children's film than he does in the
horror film in fact did we get the right
version so he kills off the store owner
bike get a lot of this a fucking pogo
stick
really that's the leprechauns weapon of
choice hey don't laugh my father went
the same way ball go stick it'll go
stick on your bow go stick and hop I'd
rue the day
so leprechaun decides it's time for an
upgrade he goes from a small childish
tricycle to a small childish Barbie car
nothing but the finest for this
dignified character
this may end up killing me but I just
got a no why don't you take that
ridiculous mask off and step out of the
car it's not nice to make fun of the
leprechaun is that so so now you're a
leprechaun huh huh huh
next you're gonna tell me you're gonna
end up in space or in the hood so
lubricant attacked the cop as he runs
away to try and hide I don't blame him I
don't think I could face the world
knowing I was beat up by a melting will
oh dear Oh Tom Bombadil is a merry
fellow by playing with his jacket and
his boots all you know
Fila oh he throws a stick at it is that
really what they teach these guys when
they come across a supernatural being
throw a stick at it Sarge Sarge I got a
question
what is it Callahan what else is totally
hypothetical what if I was attacked by a
psychotic killer leprechaun that was
trying to kill me no no very stick at it
boom is to get it right
what if it's the Easter Bunny get out of
here
please don't let me die while I'm next
to your crotch he snaps his neck really
don't know why I guess I thought he
would come up with a more imaginative
way of killing this girl and to keep it
somewhat realistic
now where's the cock of dough so he goes
back to the house looking for his goal
as he comes across a cereal called lucky
clovers now I can't imagine why the real
Lucky Charms wouldn't want their bright
and colorful image attached to this dark
and gory horror film oh well if you need
to know the answer it's magically dude
thank you no problem so he goes into the
closet pulling out all the shoes in the
house and shining them why I guess he
has a shoe fetish the others returned
home to find the place in shambles this
is crazy house going on here what could
have been a bear they sometimes come
down from the hills looking for food
yeah bears are often known for eating
food and shining shoes so Jim Carrey
bacon goes out to inspect the place when
he's caught in a bear trap that the
Leprechaun set up this results in a
pretty embarrassing fight see Jesus this
choreography is making Dolomites look
good
and now obvious dumbass line in three
two one
Nathan that was no fucking bear 300 give
me a cap Alex be careful oh good send
the little boy out where the dangerous
leprechaun is nothing but straight arrow
ethics for these people
oh yeah he can appear in a safe but he
can't get through a car window what is
the extent of his lame-ass powers anyway
we're gonna julienne it
each mommy oh god they're graceful
Bowser don't forget to hit pedestrians
to get the food oh you want me
motherfucker
oh come on is the truck made out of
styrofoam my hot wheels don't flip over
that easy
but that door must have sharp engines
they're creepy and kooky mysterious and
spooky they're all together okey The
Addams Family so Aniston finds out where
the boys hid the gold as she goes out to
return it to the leprechaun ah you ever
wear those things before nope
it's okay just pretend like you're
shooting Brad Pitt is that me gone but
how are you I'm a leprechaun me dear
yeah yeah I guess it is kinda stupid
question so he counts his gold over and
finds that one coin is still missing
that's the piece that Ozzy has in his
stomach they've got McCoy no one takes a
leprechauns
doll I don't even get it what's he gonna
do with the gold it's not like he could
just walk into a place and buy a yacht
he'll you may it what with gold he'll
cash it in what dress like that he'll
get a disguise
what kind of dissed shot up okay Alex
you gotta get two minds for Ozzy's ear
and boils up some water
I cover II
begorrah
so he attacks them some more as they try
to call for help hello please come home
as we're trapped inside here you have
Albert and I can you boom
fly up better let the poor guy up they
figure out the only person who can stop
him is Dan O'Grady the guy from the
beginning who apparently isn't an old
folks home down the street but how are
they gonna get away from Rumple shit
skin get this they just throw shoes at
him to shine ah he really has to shine
every shoe that he sees what's wrong
with this guy he is oh LD obsessive
leprechaun disorder they get to the
hospital only to discover what a shock
the Leprechaun is there waiting for she
tries to get away but oh no the
leprechaun has a wheelchair
you will take me seriously so she comes
across the O'Grady guy in the elevator
or rather on the elevator as he tells
her how to defeat him for freshly blow
from the cold patch behind the where you
gotta put it on his body to touch it and
you can turn so what you're saying is I
had to look over a four-leaf clover that
I overlooked before so of course she
comes across a bunch of clovers as she
tries to find one with four leaves
little girl should look upon each blow
this is that assay now
I just don't get how we're supposed to
find this guy scary oh I can't work just
imagine him as a child molester that'll
make him look a little spooky her
friends knock him out as they finally
find a four-leaf clover in the field and
it even close I'm surprised they didn't
find that earlier but the Leprechaun
detects odds he trying to get his final
coin fortunately the little boy pops up
saying probably the most epic line in
this movie
fuck you Lucky Charms oh those cosmic
yeah didn't think you'd hear a lime fat
awesome in this movie digit but you did
it and it's a masterpiece of writing
fucking Lucky Charms
seriously that shit is worthy of
Schwarzenegger hasta LaVista
baby though this does raise the question
how the hell would he even know what
Lucky Charms is if they have lucky
clovers in this world because when you
think about it doesn't really make sense
with them I really shouldn't be
questioning this joy no you should not
it's still cosmic so just when you think
it's dead the fucking little green
goblin refuses to die this looks like a
job for a slug in the face Jesus does
one unstable leprechaun I guess their
blood is made at a fucking nitroglycerin
so the Leprechaun is destroyed the
people are safe and they never have to
fear about seeing him again that is
until the comb guzzling whore known as
the Hollywood sequel takes over and
pimps it out like a brothel
so that was leprechaun I didn't like it
nope me neither
I mean do we really have to go into
great detail why this movie is bad the
plots ridiculous the characters are
morons and it's a fucking leprechaun I
don't know why they thought a little
green man would be frightening but he's
not he's simply not the whole plot for
this movie sounds like a Will Ferrell
scenario nothing about it sounds like a
legit horror movie it's just magically
disabled and that's all for nostalgia
weed
thanks for watching and thanks for
joining me cinema snob no thank you
Ferb no this was a giant waste of time
dick hole
you're a dick hole I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember so you don't have to
you're still a big ol dick oh no you're
a dickhole deco they pull back
fucking lucky charms